january is the time for new beginnings  like making changes to your diet  it's the fourth annual las vegas vegan  dining month  this even celebrates vegan options right  here  in las vegas restaurants like ariela's  kosher and pizza kitchen  opened in the fall of 2019 after seeing  a need for  dairy kosher food and vegan comfort food  their vegan pizza and philly cheesesteak  satisfy the most self-proclaimed  meat eaters a lot of people become very  ambitious to  go vegan plant-based  and i think it's important to show them  that it's accessible  that it's a lot easier  than a lot of people make it out to be  well 25 vegas based restaurants are  ready to serve you  ariela's pizza and kosher kitchen bronze  cafe honey salt and tacotarian  just a few to name now some proceeds  also benefit the progressive leadership  alliance of nevada a group that focuses  on social  and environmental justice right here in  the state